[Music]
because that was like a big gig to a
book
and then it only lasts one season so how
do you not get bogged down by the
disappointment
and keep your sights set on forging
forward
yeah that's a great question perry so
what am i what 1920
something around that age um number one
when you're when you're a youngster on a
show like that a lot of stuff you don't
necessarily understand with the politics
that are going on again
i wasn't i i don't remember necessarily
being as aware of what was
what was going down i do remember there
were a lot of cooks in the kitchen
you know on a show like that and um we
had such a blast
oh my gosh it was like it was so but
again it was incredible it was very
expensive show as well
um i think it's kind of you know when
something starts out as one thing i
remember
there were a lot of political undertones
to the original
pilot and you know the meaning
and i think what happens is sometimes
that can you know get diluted into
making some type of
not not soapy but just you know it
becomes this
yeah whatever whatever people feel like
it needs to be but sometimes you can
dilute something you
you lose the uniqueness or the
thinginess of it
and then it becomes then it ends up not
being really
for anyone or you don't know where to
place it you know um
so i think maybe it was a little bit to
do with that and um i mean i guess you
know
down to just ratings i guess it didn't
again i don't know i just remember
having such a blast
and then you know it was over
it's just like however i'll be really
honest with you
didn't really want to live in australia
i
loved australia no no it was beaut it
was amazing
australia's stunning and i had again it
was but i
there's a difference between working
there and then being like
you're there for eight years on a show
that runs for eight years and you know
remember these contracts
they were like let me let me sign you up
for
you know the next decade like back in
the day they were
like those pilots you know you used to
i say back in the day it wasn't like
living you know 20 years ago but it has
changed a lot right um
so um so i was kind of
like you know this might be for me
personally is as incredible as the
experience was a bit of a
bit of a blessing in disguise maybe um
that's not to say again that i didn't
love it and i wasn't disappointed
obviously that it didn't do what it was
meant to do but but just
you know i would i would definitely
always see things in the sense of okay
it's not meant to be
it's not meant to be not like to be and
by the way you sometimes you have to say
that to yourself when you're like
i really wanted that job or i really you
know but i really felt like that was one
oh gosh i've had
i've had those moments where i felt like
a job i'm like
this is it and then it's not you know
and you're just like
but i thought no but that was but then
all the signs were pointing to it you
know
um so yeah weirdly enough i think
i was i think i was okay i think i was
like you know what
there'll be something else and i was
yeah
i don't know i was i was strangely okay
about it
when you brought up the australia thing
i thought you were gonna say you
couldn't live there because of the giant
bugs because now that i'm on tic tac all
day
all the only videos i see from australia
are videos of gigantic
bugs like hiding in toilets and stuff
and i can't handle it
oh actually we did have um do you know
what we did one time
we had someone on set all the time that
would be there
specifically for that because sometimes
we'd be filming like
in the you know forest i don't know
whatever is
in some sort of you know place and um
there was one time this guy the guy was
like he shouted
cut like because he could and he said
everyone stand still
and everyone froze and there was this
black widow spider that was just
crawling across the log and then they
have to go and like find it
and there was another moment where jason
who played my dad
we're in the middle of a scene just
started going back and like
i was like i was like this is where he
right i was like oh my gosh she's gonna
die i'm literally it's gonna be on the
news it's gonna be like it's
i'm gonna be it's i was just like oh my
gosh like
and he had these giant ants that had
bitten him
and so he was just ripping off his his
shirt
and then we made a joke we were like you
just always wanted to get your kit off
any chance
you know um so i was i was snakes are
the things that i can't do
i cannot do snakes no thank you
um but um but yeah no more just because
it's just
so far away from home and i think you
know i didn't
the other thing is i never really wanted
to get
the idea of being like you have to do
this and then you have to do it for 10
years
that made me feel a little bit trapped i
didn't like the idea there was so much i
wanted to explore and do
um that actually after that experience i
said to my team i was like i don't want
to
i don't want to just sign up to
something for seven years but you know
i don't really want to do that unless it
really really really makes sense